madame la présidente Madame la
Commissaire chers collègues hier on
espérait un geste de la FIFA un hommage
aussi 1500 ouvriers morts en
construisant au Qatar dans des
conditions inhumaines des stades
démesurés climatisés en plein désert
l'hommage n'a pas eu lieu aujourd'hui la
FIFA fait pression directement sur les
joueurs pour qu'il renonce à porter un
brassard en soutien au LGBT dont les
draps droits sont bafoués au Qatar
messieurs de la FIFA il y a des limites
à la compromission alors que nous
devrions célébrer la grande fête du
football nous sommes honteux de vivre ce
choix fait en 2010 et entaché de
soupçons de corruption
certes l'actuel président de la FIFA
n'était pas là en 2010 mais où sont ses
regrets quand ils y souhaitaient ouvrir
de grandes compétitions à des pays comme
je cite la Corée du Nord la dernière
Coupe du monde en Russie où les JO en
Chine n'ont rien changé mais en fin de
compte la Coupe du Monde a agi comme un
immense révélateur l'opération séduction
du Qatar a viré au bas de buzz
planétaire et le message est clair pour
la FIFA réformez vos instances renouer
avec les valeurs d'égalité de tolérance
de transparence et d'universalité les
vraies valeurs du sport merci